من كل حدب وصوب في اسطنبول والولايات
المجاوره تداعى انصار الطاوله السداسيه
لدعم مرشحهم كمال كلجدار اوغلو في اكبر
تجمع انتخابي للمعارضه عشرات الالاف ضاق
بهم ميدان مالطا في الشطر الاسيوي في
اسطنبول الحق والحقوق والعداله هو لسان
حال انصار المعارضه وزعماء الطاوله
السداسيه الذين حضروا في هذا التجمع
سيذهب اكثر من 800 الف شاب في اسطنبول
يصوتون لاول مره الى صناديق الاقتراع
سنستبدل الحكومه الاستبداديه بوسائل
ديمقراطيه
المعارضه بعدتها وعديدها ارادت تحدي
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بحجم
الحشود والتجمعات الانتخابيه فاختارت
اسطنبول للمواجهه في رساله قويه بان فرص
مرشحها بالفوز كبيره هذه المره الانتخابات
تشهد منافسه شرسه بخلاف المرات السابقه في
الاسبوع الاخير ستحسم الكثير من الاصوات
خصوصا انه يشهد نشاطا كبيرا من السياسيين
ارى ان تحالف الامه متقدم بخطوه على
التحالف
وعود انتخابيه كثيره قدمها زعماء المعارضه
للناخبين في هذا التجمع لا سيما الوعود
الاقتصاديه وتوسيع مجال الحريات وحقوق
الانسان على ما يقولون
دائما للحريات والعداله والحقوق لذلك
ساصوت له اعتقد انه سيجلب السلامه لتركيا
قد جسديه منذ عام 2010 طلبت حزب العداله
والتنميه مرارا بتوفير فرصه عمل لي لكن لم
يستجيبوا لطلبي هذا التجمع الضخم للمعارضه
من المنتظر ان يقابله تجمع ضخم اخر في
اسطنبول يوم الاحد لكن هذه المره لتحالف
الشعب ومرشحه الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في
الايام الكبيره على حجر مؤيديه في
الميادين وتمثل اسطنبول اهم استعراض القوه
لمرشح المعارضه في مواجهه اردوغان زيدان
العربيه اسطنبول لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات